[Music]
sandwiches we I'm gonna get Susan she
was a ham and Swiss on rye with lettuce
onion and a John mustard
one bite and we were in love all the
guys made for honey you know the typical
you love her so much won't you marry her
believe me I looked into it at the time
it wasn't legal bill I know you I know
you have a sandwich that comes to mind
you want to tell me that story
I do New York City 7th Avenue in 1996
the police are dispersing people from
around this body a guy jumped out of the
Time Square Hilton there he was covered
in the sheet it was horrible
why am I talking about this I was about
one got a sandwich oh right right right
so next to the body was a brown paper
bag and I was really curious so why the
cops weren't looking I grabbed the bag
when I opened that bag there was the
best tuna fish on the kaiser roll
[Music]
ciabatta bread smoked chicken breast
sun-dried tomato provolone and a basil
pesto sauce was greatest moment of my
life and I have a wife and three sons
October 8th 1988 I was working on Murphy
Brown at the time and that day I woke up
hungover and hungry like you wouldn't
believe
because I was out on a night party with
my good old buddy Billy Idol those days
the only thing I kept in the fridge was
a pack of cigarettes and a loaded gun so
I ran to the commissary on lunch break
or did my normal dozen hard-boiled eggs
and I added two BLTs wheat bread Mayo
first one sucked it was horrible
but that second BLT it was damn good
I've got it made me cry sometimes it
still does
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll watch that any day
[Applause]